[Music]
hey guys
a lot of you've been asking the question
can i cook
and the answer really is you surprised
me
how you are i'm no master chef and i
think that's no secret
because you've seen my meal prep video
in the past
which was really more of like a snack
prep video rather than a true meal but
today
you're gonna be cooking with me an
entire meal courtesy of blue apron a
meal kit delivery service
which brings the ingredients and the
recipes right to your doorstep enough
with the talking
it's time to get serious wait is a
flower in the shot
probably don't need this right now let's
open the box first the first step to
cooking a great meal
is picking out what you're gonna cook
and then picking up all the ingredients
but thankfully we don't have to do that
today because i have this box
right here that was delivered right to
my door
let's get cooking so you have your
chiller bag in case you're not home the
food stays cool with the ice
the recipe we're gonna be cooking today
is the tahini chicken with crispy
smashed potatoes and snow pea
tomato salad let's take a look what's
fully inside this box knickknacks aka
the sauces
got the radishes very healthy vegetable
grape tomatoes
boneless skinless chicken snow peas
golden potatoes
and a garlic bulb i got my ingredients
and i'm ready to start cooking but i
want to get you your own blue apron box
delivered so down below in the
description box i dropped the link
first hundred people who sign up will
get 50 bucks off the first blue apron
order let's
get cooking 43 carbs with six sugars
52 grams of protein and a big highlight
trans fat
is zero so the first part is going to be
preparing the potatoes
let me get my medium pot these are pots
the medium
would fall right in here let's do
something like they do in clothing we'll
go
small medium large
extra large medium pot of salt and water
boiling on
high now look legit wash
and dry the fresh produce washing kits
radishes snow peas grape tomatoes i
don't know if this is the right way to
wash
produce but it feels very efficient
large
dice the potatoes i'm gonna operate on
these potatoes right now
advanced move two potatoes in one let's
talk ingredients
radishes what are rockstar vegetables
you got vitamins
a e c b6 fiber then you got your grape
tomatoes which have been always my
favorite tomato to eat because they're
so bite-sized and crunchy i love that
they got lycopene which is a really
important antioxidant
which has a lot of health benefits add
potatoes and cook 11 to 13 minutes
while stirring but where's my cooking
spoon for the stirring
using a strainer drain the cooked
potatoes and pat dry with paper towels
strain strain strain strain strain
strain strain
fat pad pad pad pad pack transfer to a
cutting board
using the flat side of your knife
carefully smash each potato piece
once the flat they say a good chef
always tastes his food
half the piece crosswise have the
tomatoes place in bowl and season with
salt and pepper
cut and discard the ends of the radishes
half lengthwise then thinly slice
crosswise
look how green and colorful this plate
already looks peel and finely chop the
garlic
using the flat side of your knife smash
it until it resembles a paste
in a large bowl combine the vinegar
tahini one tablespoon olive oil
tablespoon of water
and as much of the garlic paste as you
like season with salt and pepper
whisk until smooth fill the medium bowl
with ice water and a pinch of salt
set aside add the half piece to the pot
of boiling water
cook stirring frequently careful coming
through hot hot [ __ ]
you say to immediately put them in the
ice water you know in medicine we have
to sometimes shock the patient
but right now the process that i'm doing
here
is called shocking the peas
pat the chicken dry with paper towels
season with salt and pepper on both
sides
in a large pan heat two teaspoons of
olive oil on medium high until
hot throw in the chicken on the pan
can't handle the heat get out kitchen
[Music]
looks good add this mashed potatoes in
an even layer
season with salt and pepper cook four to
five minutes per side until brown and
crispy i'm going to be a potato master
chef
[Music]
no it's not a fire
[Music]
oh man it's getting hot
oh man it's getting hot okay switch
gloves
now this glove is getting hot dan
[Music]
to the large bowl of dressing add the
chocolate seasoned tomatoes and sliced
[Music]
radishes
[Music]
look at this creation
that really does look like the picture
now the question is does it taste like
the picture
that's good put the camera down let's
finish this and we'll talk after we're
done
that was a great meal i'm not even
joking like 10 out of 10 delicious
and i cooked it myself if i can do it
you definitely can do it
more and more i find myself drifting
away from ordering takeout
and the more i find myself wanting to
prepare the meals on my own
it's really critical to know what goes
into your foods
i have patients that come in all the
time with worsening congestive heart
failure
or swelling in their legs and i at first
question i ask them is how much salt
they're consuming
and most of them say well doctor i don't
salt my food at all but then when i ask
further they eat takeout quite often
when you eat takeout you just
don't know what you're getting i mean
there's a whole host of things that you
don't know
about how your food's being prepared i
always try and empower
you at home and even my patients in the
hospital to take control of their health
and an easy first step
is to monitor what foods you're eating
and watch those nutrition facts
and with a service like blue apron they
make it easy
no-brainer i strongly encourage you go
in my description box and click that
link and sign up for blue apron
the first hundred people who sign up
will get 50 bucks off their first two
weeks of blue apron
that's a no-brainer now i know you have
some comments or critiques about my
cooking ability
so go ahead jump in the comments section
i'm a big boy i can take it get down
there also and ask your questions
because
i'm active in the comment section and
every month i'm still going to be doing
the responding to comments video
as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]